had a significant reduction in the last month of the size of my lip
bilbs. I've been alternating, I've armected in pendizol with other recommended
treatments. Coming up on the last week of the pendizol treatment and asking if I
should stick with pendizol or switch back to iburemectic for the next six weeks.
So just understand I can't legally answer a question regarding medication on this
platform. We are live on Facebook and YouTube and etc. So I have to be careful of that. So this
person should contact us so we can talk about that. Pendizol and iburemectic have both got
really good reports in the last couple of months with some data that has come out for treatment
of cancer. And where doctors have been who we didn't. In fact, we had the FDA come after us.
Gosh, what was that? A year and a half ago that made us take down all our data on our on our
website on pendizol. They said to be 11. I can't remember how to page letter, but it was like
threat need to sue the pants off me if I didn't. We didn't follow through immediately
with taking everything down. We had seven days or something to get everything. Take it down.
What a crock. But it's that's the that's the things that we deal with. So I'll call it as
that I can be careful with any advice on any medications put out to where the world would see them.
Yeah, YouTube is taking down our videos almost on a weekly basis as well.
Silly ones, two of them really could have picked a little more controversial video to take down.
Of course, it's just their AI that's picking stuff up. But it's just it's a little frustrating
that they could have, you know, photographic videos all over YouTube. But you can't have, you know,
videos that tell people to take mushrooms for their, you know, immune system.
Okay, so next question that we had. So keep asking questions about that.
But yeah, in general, basically keep alternating or stick with what's working.
Obviously, you know, we want to stick with what's working.
There, there isn't anything wrong with what you're dealing with anything to pulse stuff.
So pulsing nutrition and or what you asked about here can be beneficial. Our body can get used to things.
So going off of things for a couple of weeks or switching to something else for a period of time can
be beneficial. So you can see better results too. So don't feel bad about doing that.